record is like you only play you play
the you playing it for the Dirk first
yeah because that's the part people sing
along too and Dirk is able to rap and do
like certain tricks and stuff on songs
by tricks I mean like parts that
everyone's gonna sing along to like uh
don't play a little boy in the club we
don't listen like that that no one knows
the talent that that one line takes [__]
the content of just the melody like to
stop everyone and what we're gonna sing
along to Dirk has that and he can rap
and he can make music I'm just not
running I just maybe it's my age maybe
it's right my region I I just not my
[__] did you have any time to see uh his
sit down with academic [__] no I haven't
I I saw the one clip of have you seen
the clips yeah
what was the clip about the Gunner thing
I think that was the only thing I saw
you and academics still uh you guys have
a pretty uh you guys have a conflict I
wouldn't say so well I think he he
doesn't like you much what but you know
what but it's crazy that he doesn't like
you much and you guys have kind of had
this back and forth for years ever since
has every Day Struggle was on right
I don't know if it's been a back and
forth well I've certainly said things
what before but not anything that but I
also when you were discussing the list
you said nice things
yeah and that's where the internet
will will they'll see this clip and be
like w Frac no no I'm an objective human
being like I know there's nuance and
objectiveness to every situation yeah
and we're also on the internet so like
yes if we're talking about a list I
believe academics should be on that if
something is in person
I'm not going to talk about the list
right I'm gonna ask you like in terms of
these are drastically different things I
can give people their credit where it's
due for sure I was gonna say in terms of
like we kind of started this combo
talking about hip-hop media for a sec
but like how do you kind of see and I'm
happy uh those this is not going to come
across I know people are going to think
this is a sarcastic shot I'm very happy
that um he was not harmed in that home
invasion
because that that could have went really
bad so I I'm this is a real thing he
said horrible lies and weird [__] about
me I'm very happy he was not harming
that that home invasion that could have
got really bad when's the home invasion
uh from my understanding recently two
people who tried to break into it yeah
very recently and they were arrested he
could I don't know if he was making that
up or not but wait didn't you send him
like a Christmas card didn't you send
something to his house like we're like
people were like oh that that's that's
[__] yes okay that was so funny
though like
Elizabeth I have no issue with anybody I
think that's funny that that's a that's
a that's like a thing good good keep
keep the narrative going I think it's
[__] hilarious and I do mean this
wholeheartedly I know his fans are gonna
hate this because they want me to say
something I know my fans are gonna be
like was this some [__] [__] like the
amount of personal things that I'm so
glad with what's been going on he was
not harmed in that home invasion
because from what I read it could have
been those guys was ready so was he just
not home
I don't know the foot something about
some girl set him up if I'm him I got a
safe room at the house I think a girl
set him up but it's not my story to tell
I just saw some clips you know I stay on
Reddit so I do see what other people
type I can't say that they are the best
source but yeah I saw that something
happened with the girl set him up and
two people were arrested and they had
guns somebody was unlocking the door at
his house
his girlfriend and listen I don't wanna
I may disagree with a lot of [__]
things that that kid
stands for says whatever I'm so happy he
wasn't harmed because this [__] this
[__] is getting insane with home
invasions and I want to see anybody just
people losing their life in general okay
that kid uh I think it was in Texas that
kid who like posted the picture and
standing in the guy's blood and then
that same day got killed did you see
that no
and even though it's what he was saying
I think his I think act's Mom was in
there like that that [__] is like
that's that [__] is [__] up bro so
that's like I don't yeah that's just not
funny it's just not cool like I feel for
bro yeah are you like uh you some would
say he may deserve it but I don't think
someone deserves that like that's my
thing with Act is like I think when he
first came under the scene because I was
not hip to his YouTube [__] at all prior
I had no idea who he was prior to
Everyday struggle so
when the everyday struggle started to
pop I kind of got a kick out of this
like internet dude who genuinely came
off like a fan who was like happy to be
there in a lot of these conversations he
was having because Joe Budden would be
there yeah and that's why I like that
conversation with the Migos the BET was
so funny because he just was so green
and like happy to be talking to the
Migos and I think there was a moment
where he just became like big ack and it
was like
you know what I mean like his Persona of
like being like this [__] this guy
you know and I'm like sometimes I like
and I respect dudes like he's a hustler
you know like I ain't mad at him like
but I also think a certain point in
times will act it's like
you you kind of don't seem like the
greatest dude you know like uh but I
don't I don't know him personally yeah
neither do I to be fair yeah as much as
there's been a an insane narrative that
anything in my life has been affected by
him which is like absolutely
egregiously false and hilarious I I
don't yeah it's more power to him like
keep going bro have a blast like there's
nothing has been affected in my life